Cody actually said to me the other day
he's like why don't you just move up
there
so I'm like
uh that was not my intention
at this point I just I don't know what
to do I am lost
[Music]
I felt empty
Sister Wives star Mary Brown clearly
hurt by her husband Cody suggesting she
move away from the rest of the family
the reason I'm suggesting this to Mary
is is honestly as a family anymore it
doesn't feel like we actually interact
that much it's a estranged marriage it's
it's a marriage that needs to work out
some stuff adding to the challenges of
that marriage Mary's now reeling from
her mother's death
it's been really hard like trying to
just like figure out life without her
and what to do and how to do it and
she's having to figure out what to do
with her family's Utah bed and breakfast
over 300 miles away from the browns's
compound in Arizona Cody solution Mary
should just live there I'm not even
trying to push her away I'm just she's
she's laying this burden that she has at
my feet about the struggle she has about
what to do with Lizzie's Heritage Inn
now that her mom's past and and I'm like
well here's the solution for you yeah
that doesn't sit well with her I told
him I didn't want to I told him I had no
intention of doing that and he was kind
of surprised you know he's like oh
really I guess I'm still just in this
place with him or he's still in this
place where he thinks that like the
point of me buying this was
to get away
and
that really saddens me this is the
latest in a string of challenges for
Mary and Cody their relationship has
been Rocky since at least 2015 when Mary
found herself involved in a catfishing
Scandal I thought I was talking to a man
online
it wasn't a man
it was a woman
pretending to be a man we've had a real
struggle we have some very difficult
conversations but that in conversation
includes
hey
I'm not mad anymore I'm Not Angry
Anymore I'm not hurt anymore
so you know that's real progress and now
with Christine leaving the plural
marriage Mary struggles to face all her
issues at once I just feel like I'm like
doing all I can to reassure people that
I'm not going anywhere dealing with all
this plus the BMB plus losing mom plus
my conflict with Cody I need to just
figure out
what it is that I can control
that
I can get through at this point I just I
don't know what to do I am lost I felt
empty I was with all relationships you
know whether it's spouses or friends or
family or Sisters You've Got the ups and
downs you just do and it's just a matter
of what your commitment level is and you
know what it is that you want and you
know you just keep working at it
sometimes things aren't better but
sometimes but then they always do get
better that's the thing that I find you
know you just work through it and then
you get to a point that's good
foreign
[Music]